we were talking just just before the
show and I was running this poll on
social media and somebody actually you
know suggested to me so I thought that I
would frame it this way uh guys you've
got the option of two twin sisters
they're both 30 they're both gorgeous
one's been married and now divorced and
she's got three kids but her Notch count
is two she's only been with two guys the
other one her other twin sister never
got married partied through her twenties
traveled around and racked up a large
Notch count let's say 50 guys which one
would you rather have overwhelmingly
guys so far on that poll are selecting
the single mom which is unusual because
when you invite a single mom into your
life now you're raising another guy's
kits right which which is not a feature
of what men are looking for in their own
life right like they want Assurance of
attorney so they want to raise their own
kids so yeah it's a very bizarre Dynamic
that's sort of evolving out of where we
are and Human Nature
yeah you know you you talk about uh
Notch count right body count if you will
and um you know women would say well
this is unfair why can why why is it
cool that a man be like a James Bond
character right well look they like that
character so it's not it's not men's
fault right but you know that's what
women choose yeah right they choose that
ABS with overwhelming uh you know
majority right they'll totally choose
that yeah and uh so you know James Bond
can go and sleep around uh but yet that
standard when men apply it to women it's
you know no they want a woman who's
chased who's uh who's not promiscuous is
is that fair
look uh life isn't fair you know life
isn't fair for for men or women you know
depending on how you want to Stack it up
and we we can spend a lot of time
talking about what's not fair to men you
know we could talk about how men rarely
see their kids in divorce we can talk
about how it's it's more common for a
guy's kids to be raised by
um his ex-wife's boyfriend and he spends
more time with his kids than he does we
can talk about a lot of stuff that's not
fair and those kids are much more
susceptible to abuse absolutely
treatment with with not having their own
father yeah I mean like we could talk
about how it's not fair that men are
considered you know success objects like
there's this coin phrase gold digger
right there's not a lot of of that
phrase being used on the opposite sex
it's it's always used on women seeking
men's resources but that's that's fine
that is a feature of women's sexual
strategy because when you're pregnant
and you're raising a kid you can't go
out and hunt you can't protect yourself
from you know the big bad animals in the
forest or the woods or whatever it's you
know it's men that have traditionally in
the past provided that service so yeah
there's a lot of things that aren't fair
but that's just the reality of how men
and women made select I mean there's a
lot of guys out there today right now
that are invisible to women on the
sexual Marketplace absolutely invisible
and they're frustrated to no end you
know they they say things to me like all
the time like I I'm a really good guy I
have a good job I make fifty thousand
dollars a year I have a car I pay my
rent I don't have any debt but nobody
wants to go out with me nobody will
nobody even sees me and that's that's
the reality of that guy's life that's
not fair for him as well but that's
reality of his life right guys guys are
expected to chase Excellence right like
you cannot just resign yourself to
mediocrity or to an average life because
women because they're hypergamous are
always choosing the best guys exactly
yeah it's um it's interesting that
um women get to just show up
and men have to earn men men are made
women are just born right like a woman
needs to preserve her value on the
sexual Marketplace which is not running
around of course uh a man needs to
create his value on the sexual
Marketplace because again men compete
women's shoes so men are doing the work
they're competing they're going out
there they're doing all the difficult
things that's generally why they make
more money because they're because
they're taking greater risks and that's
okay you don't want the mother of your
kid to take great risks you want them to
be careful and protect your kid so
that's why the Sexes are complementary
but we've moved completely away from
that and you know men and women have
been bombarded with this message and
they're now completely drunk on this
Kool-Aid of
egalitarianism everything's equal men
and women are the same if you were born
as a biological male it doesn't matter
call yourself a woman you can compete
with women and beat them in every single
swimming event ever sort of thing so we
have this strange bizarre sort of thing
evolving and nobody's really doing
anything to stop it it just keeps kind
of going in that direction right right
the thing the thing I would say that's
really important for women to hear or
parents with daughters to hear is you
know it's a key phrase what you just
said women need to preserve their value
and one of the ways they do that is by
being prudish
yeah I mean that's the reality of it and
uh I I mean that's actually the reality
of the way that it works in the rest of
the most of the world right like right
the vast majority of the world that's
the way that it works and and throughout
history and throughout history yeah yeah
we just have
somehow the Western culture has just
decided that that's not the way it works
like in the last 30 years how to get
those two toasters in the two house my
friend yeah yeah exactly exactly it's
it's crazy so
um what advice uh you know would you
have for for men and for women and you
know men are the Chasers women are the
choosers as has been said right yeah
um so you know what advice would you
have for each side there like you know
for example when we talk about women
preserving their value how can a man
find that woman or at least know what
kind of woman she is because they're
never going to tell the truth right you
know you're you're gonna have to read
between the lines and
um you know for example uh one one girl
that I dated had had been to you know
over a hundred countries I mean what
what do you think she's doing right well
that's a red flag I mean like you know
traveling that that much to me is a red
flag somebody that knows a whole bunch
of really important people's a red flag
somebody that's you know like if you
look at their social media presence and
she's an attractive gal and you see her
on private jets Yachts sports cars
exotic car rallies that's a red flag you
know she's been around so
um I mean you're asking a lot of
questions there so I mean my advice to
guys is to build their value is to focus
on themselves make themselves their own
mental point of origin stop chasing gals
stop setting for mediocrity Chase
Excellence not women build a life for
yourself and when you are going to deal
with women be Discerning in your taste
right just because you know a girl gives
you some attention responds you and
wants to see you again or maybe you know
wants to claim you sort of thing doesn't
mean that you need to accept that right
I mean the biggest decision that you can
make it in your life as a guy or
probably one of the most important ones
is who's your who is it that you're
going to invite in your life even beyond
that who is it that might make the
mother of your kids right because if
she's made some bad choices in her past
and I've got this chapter in my book on
red flags and I kind of get into details
about you know some of the warning signs
that guy should look out for then that
will then that will give them an
opportunity to sort of vet for that now
as far as what women need to do they
need to stop listening to this nonsense
about everybody's equal and exactly the
same and recognize that the Sexes are
complementary and they're not
competitive and it's okay for women to
be women and for men to be men and it's
okay for women to be feminine and men to
be masculine and it's okay all that's
good
um the key thing that women have have to
remember is that they need to preserve
their value like we said earlier I mean
there's no guy that's ever looked at a
woman a gorgeous woman who's got three
degrees on her wall framed in the most
beautiful mahogany ever practicing
Doctor Surgeon whatever and said to the
friend hey did you see the degree on
that gal they're always looking at the
Optics of her beauty like the figure and
the form of beauty comes in the looks
and that's what guys are looking at and
that's what they need to preserve and to
protect but we're not doing that anymore
so we've got this messed up sort of
environment there's there's no woman
that usually shares their pot of gold
with a guy but guys like a very wealthy
guy will change change a broke woman's
life but a very wealthy woman won't even
look at a broke guy I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out